une salle tristement vide pour un sujet
ô combien courant dans nos régions
ces personnes sont médiatrice familiale
leur quotidien conflit en tous genres
familiaux conjugaux voire même
quelquefois de voisinage le lien
familial qui se détruit suite par
exemple à une séparation est évidemment
l'enfant qui est directement concerne
donc notre rôle justement c'est de
mettre en place pas de mettre en place
pour fait d'accompagner les parents dans
une séparation qui se passe dans de
bonnes conditions
et toujours dans l'intérêt de l'enfant
on estime à près de 70% les familles
martiniquaises au bord de la rupture
elles sont encore peu nombreuses à faire
le pas vers la médiation démarche
pourtant efficace pour permettre aux
familles les plus déchiré de se
reconstruire de trouver un terrain
d'entente sans forcément passer par les
interminables procédures juridiques les
pareils faut qu'ils sachent que avec la
médiation et de vendre on va trouver
ensemble des solutions
on va répartir les tâches et des
responsabilités c'est un document qu'on
appelle protocole d'accord pourra être
établie et ramener vers le juge pour
qu'il puisse être homologué jusqu'à ce
samedi 23
plusieurs communes accueillent des
spécialistes de la question de la
construction et reconstruction familiale
pour info la médiation est conventionné
par la caisse d'allocations familiales
des tarifs varient entre 2 et 50 euros
c'est selon les revenus du demandeur